- So, you've also got a
new movie, "Songbird."
- I do.
- You are constantly working, girl.
Okay. So how did you do
all of this in a pandemic?
- I'm so grateful.
I was able to shoot the first movie
ever to be shot during a global pandemic,
which is incredible.
And I remember, recently
I came home from work,
and there was a package at the door,
which we know is really
exciting right now,
when we get packages.
- Yeah, yeah, like Christmas.
- And it was from our producers,
from Michael Bay and my
director, Adam Mason.
And it was a t-shirt with
the first slate of the movie.
And they said that this
slate will go down in history
as the first film to ever
be shot during a pandemic.
So, it's incredible.
I feel so honored.
- Wow. And you're, speaking
of all of this also,
on a really cool human note,
you're now a new, you're an
ambassador for UNICEF, right?
- For UNICEF, yes. Yes.
- That's crazy.
So, how did that come about
and what exactly does that entail?
Does it kind of happen after
you're allowed to start traveling again?
- Yes. Well, I've been supporting UNICEF
for a few years now,
and this also goes back
to my mom when I was young.
She always kind of instilled in us
that the most important
thing that we can do
is to give back.
And she would always
refer to Audrey Hepburn,
who was the first UNICEF
ambassador, and who's like my icon.
And now to be, to join those ranks
and to be able to be a UNICEF ambassador
is the most important
thing that I'll ever do.
And I'm so honored.
And it basically means, yes,
I do get to go on field trips,
and I once traveled to Brazil with them.
And I see firsthand, like,
the schools that they're building,
the girls that they actually
save through education,
which is kind of like where my heart lies.
And I'm just so thrilled to see
where this journey will take us.
- Me as well.
I think it's really key,
too, like, right now,
because I have kids, and
my mom was a teacher.
And it, education is so important.
And we take it for
granted in this country.
- Because we don't have to think about it.
- It's offered, because
we don't think about it.
And now that our kids are,
my kids are dying to go to school.
- [Sofia] How beautiful is that?
- Like, my little boy is
actually already able to go,
but my little girl is
dying to physically, like,
be in school.
- 'Cause they know what it's like to not.
- 'Cause they, now they
know what it's like
to not have that.
And it's been kind of taken away.